bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france vous êtes à
nos mères donc le confinement strict il
a donc débuté puisqu'il est tard là bas
quelle est l'atmosphère
l'atmosphère est à l'unité et à
l'inquiétude parce que la situation est
gravissime pour le pays
puisque le co vide et en plus c'est le
variante delta est entré dans notre pays
et circule depuis plusieurs jours avec
les endroits éloignés et et ce au moment
où
la vaccination commençait seulement à
prendre son élan nous sommes en retard
depuis plusieurs mois assez peu de
calédoniens aller se faire vacciner
et ensuite de cela nous avons quarante
neuf machines de réanimation mais le
personnel pour en faire fonctionner que
la moitié
donc parallèlement au confinement il y à
une opération de vaccination à grande
échelle et de détection qui est mis en
oeuvre par les municipalités et les
provinces la nouvelle calédonie est
divisé en province et par le
gouvernement parce que son président
hier soir a prononcé un discours très
fort et a appelé à l'union sacrée
de toutes les institutions du pays de
toutes les associations et c'est ce qui
est en train d'être mises en oeuvre
les calédoniens justement comment ils
réagissent face à la vaccination
globalement et sont favorables ou pas
eh bien jusqu'à présent nous étions un
pays sans sanco vide ce qui fait qu'il y
avait finalement pas d'incitation forte
à se faire vacciner et depuis quelques
jours à la faveur de ce qui se passe en
polynésie
les calédoniens les polynésiens ont
beaucoup de liens et ce qui se passe en
polynésie a impressionné fortement la
population est naturellement avec
l'arrivée du coc vide et bien
alors là c'est la ruée dans les centres
de vaccination à peu près partout dans
le pays que ce soit au nord au sud et
également dans les îles vous pensez que
ce 3ème confinement strict il influence
justement les calédoniens et les
influences justement pour aller se faire
vacciner
oui naturellement ce qui influence le
plus les calédoniens je le disais c'est
le fait que
désormais
nous avons onze cas de co vide les
spécialistes estiment qu' il faudra
multiplier
se nomme pas à trois patrons pardon est
ce qui fait que nous craignons
une envolée de l'épidémie parce que
nous ne sommes pas assez vacciner tout
simplement
tout à l'heure vous parlez de la
vaccination en précisant que justement
il ya une campagne de vaccination donc
massifs qui se met en place mais que les
personnels ne sont pas au rendez vous
est ce qu'on met suffisamment les moyens
en calédonie enfin bien la métropole
justement pour permettre à cette
campagne d'être un succès
oui
la durée du confinement il est
nécessaire aussi pour apprécier
l'occupation des suite à l'épidémie des
hôpitaux justement pour prendre la
mesure dans quinze jours de l'occupation
des hôpitaux est de savoir si oui ou non
nous aurons besoin de personnel
supplémentaire mais c'est l'hypothèse
qui semble-t-il est privilégiée dont un
au niveau du gouvernement et des
différentes directions de l'action
sanitaire et sociale
[Musique]
donc on surveille
c'est c'est très récent prince est
depuis hier les premiers cas ont été
détectés même si probablement le virus
circule depuis plusieurs jours ça qui
est inquiétant donc on attend le nombre
de cas il sera détectée demain après
demain les jours qui viennent pour
prendre la mesure des besoins en
personnel sanitaire par rapport à ce
qu'on a mais d'ores et déjà la
mobilisation et maximum à tous niveaux
dans le pays aussi bien pour la santé
publique que les les équipements privés
en somme
s'agissant vous savez qu'en métropole
l'activité économique a bien repris en
en outre-mer peut-être que la situation
elle est différente notamment en
nouvelle calédonie avec ce confinement
il ya les vols qui sont suspendues les
établissements
qui accueillent du public fermé donc ça
va avoir un impact on imagine sur
l'économie locale
oui c'est un impact colossal mais c'est
déjà le cas depuis un an et demi pour
notre industrie touristique qui ne qui
fonctionne presque plus puisque nous
n'avons plus de touristes de l'extérieur
nous n'avons plus de tourisme de
croisière alors qu'il était en pleine
expansion
heureusement l'activité minière et
métallurgique
fonctionne et il y à des protocoles
particulier pour la protection des
différents ports minier et mais sinon
pour ce confinement là eh bien
naturellement
toutes les activités économiques
recevant du public principalement
les restaurateurs pas raison les lieux
de distraction tout est fermé et
pas toutes les activités économiques
pourront se développer et ça pour la
troisième fois ce qui fait que le monde
économique calédonien est très
préoccupée par les conséquences de ce
troisième confinement merci beaucoup à
vous à 10 mètres course tôt fitch je
rappelle que vous êtes historien et
spécialiste de la nouvelle calédonie
merci à vous